let's continue the deep analysis of your
tweets
[Laughter]
you said that determinism in a tweet
determinism and randomness play
important roles in understanding what
life is so let me ask on this topic of
free will what is determinism
what is randomness and why the heck do
they have anything
to do with understanding life yeah
and you threw free will in there just
throwing all the stuff in the bag
are they not related no no they are they
are related then no no
sorry i was being unfair you didn't even
capitalize the tweet by the way it was
all lower case
i must have been angry oh that was was
saying can you analyze the emotion
behind that no i actually died
frustration
yeah maybe so i already argued that i
don't
think that can happen without that whole
causal history and so i guess in some
sense
um the determinism for me arises because
of the causal history
um and i'm not really sure actually
about
whether the universe is random or
deterministic i just had this sort of
intuition for a long time i'm not sure
if i agree with it anymore but it's
still kind of lingering and i don't know
what to do with this question
but it seems to me you know so there's
you ask the question what is life
but you could also why life why does
life exist what does the universe need
life for
not that the universe has needs but you
know we have to answer percentiles
things sometimes to talk about them
um and i had this feeling that if it was
possible
for a cup or a desk ornament or a phone
on mars to spontaneously fluctuate into
existence the universe didn't need life
to create those objects it wasn't
necessary for their existence it was
just
a random fluke event and so somehow to
me it seems that
it can't be that those things formed by
rand random processes they actually have
to have a set of causes
that accrue and form those things and
they have to have that history
and so it seems to me that that life was
somehow deeply related
to the question of whether the
underlying rules of our universe had
randomness in them or they were fully
deterministic and in some ways you can
think about life as
being the most deterministic part of
physics because it's where the
causes are um precise in some sense
um or most stable so like most stable
yes
most reliable most reliable for for our
for how we for the tools of physics but
what um right well so
where's randomness come from then if
okay so you you were at
uh speaking with i've gone in a tangent
so i'm not sure where we are in the
yeah all of the universe is a kind of
tangent so we're embracing the tangent
you